en el vídeo pasado vimos cómo balancear
una reacción redox cuando se encuentra
en una solución ácida en este vídeo
vamos a balancear una reacción redox
pero que se encuentra en una solución
básica y estas son ligeramente más
complicadas pero vamos a utilizar más o
menos la misma técnica la principal
diferencia tiene que ver con estos
protones que agregamos en el paso número
4 porque como estamos en una solución
básica estos van a ser neutralizados por
grupos hidroxi los entonces cuando
llegamos al paso 6 vamos a juntar las 12
mil reacciones pero también vamos a
agregar esos grupos hidroxi los que
neutralizan a estos protones lo que
vamos a agregar
agregar en millones hidroxilo el
procedimiento es el mismo que en el
vídeo pasado pero al final vamos a
agregar a estos aniones hidroxi los que
son necesarios porque como estamos en
una solución básica necesitamos estos
grupos hidroxilo para neutralizar a los
protones del paso 4 ok entonces al igual
que en el vídeo pasado vamos a empezar
con los estados de oxidación si
empezamos con el año hipoclorito sabemos
que el oxígeno en esta molécula tiene un
estado de oxidación de menos 2 ok pero
sabemos que en total la suma de todos
los estados de oxidación tiene que ser
menos 1 entonces el cloro debe de tener
un estado de oxidación de más 1 porque
más uno menos 2 es igual a menos 1 si
ahora vamos a este compuesto de cromo y
creo que la mejor forma de analizar esto
es recordar que la unión hidróxido todo
completito tiene un estado de oxidación
pero tenemos cuatro de estos aniones
hidróxidos entonces menos 1 por 4 nos da
un total de menos 4 sin embargo en
términos de oxidación la molécula
completa tiene un -1 porque la carga de
este jon es menos 1 así es que el cromo
debe de tener un estado de oxidación de
más 3 porque más 3 menos 4 es menos 1
que hay el cromo tiene un estado de
oxidación de más 3 en esta molécula
bueno ahora vamos con los productos
tenemos aquí una unión cromato y aquí el
oxígeno tiene un estado de oxidación de
menos 2 tengo 4 oxígenos por lo cual
tengo un total de menos 8 necesito
llegar a un total de menos 2 que es la
carga de este ión entonces el cromo debe
de tener un estado de oxidación de más 6
porque más 6 menos 8 me da menos 2
6 y finalmente con el año el cloruro
tiene una carga de menos 1 por lo tanto
su estado de oxidación es menos 1 en
términos de que átomos se están oxidando
y que átomos se están reduciendo lo que
tenemos que ver es donde hay un
incremento en el estado de oxidación y
esos son los que se están oxidando y
para ver cuáles se están reduciendo
tenemos que ver qué estados de oxidación
están decreciendo ok por aquí el cromo
tenía un estado de oxidación más 3 pero
por acá los productos ahora tienen un
estado de oxidación más 6 así es que el
cromo se está oxidando y el cloro
empieza con un estado de oxidación más
uno
y en la reacción termina con un estado
de oxidación -1 así es que su estado de
oxidación se reduce y el cloro se está
reduciendo así es que podemos concluir
que está habiendo una oxidación y una
reducción aunque ahí se trata de una
reacción redox y ahora si podemos
escribir las semi reacciones o
reacciones parciales una semi reacción
de oxidación y una semi reacción de
reducción
y en esta ocasión vamos a escribir la
semi reacción de reducción primero
entonces qué es lo que se redujo el
cloro fue el que se redujo entonces
vamos a empezar poniendo aquí se l o
menos
se reduce al transformarse en cloruro
esta es la semi reacción de reducción
por otro lado el elemento que se oxida
es el que involucraba al cromo en el
compuesto de cromo que era
r
hidróxido 4 hidróxidos y una carga
negativa que durante la reacción se
transforma en cromato ok
cr o 4 con dos cargas negativas y esta
es nuestra semi reacción de oxidación
primer paso listo ahora vamos con el
segundo paso que hoy queremos balancear
los átomos que no sean oxígeno o
hidrógeno así es que vamos por aquí con
nuestra semi reacción de reducción y
pues aquí el átomo que no es oxígeno ni
hidrógeno es el cloro ok pero tenemos la
misma cantidad de átomos de cloro en los
reactivos que en los productos entonces
con respecto al cloro estás en mi
reacción ya está balanceada y ahora en
la semi reacción de oxidación eso aplica
al cromo aunque ya tenemos un átomo de
cromo en la izquierda y un átomo de
cromo en la derecha así es que está semi
reacción también está balanceada
lo que en este caso en esta reacción
este paso ya está hecho pero ten mucho
cuidado porque en algunas otras
reacciones si tienes que balancear estos
átomos y va a afectar el resultado final
bueno ya ahora vamos con el paso 3
balancea el oxígeno agregando agua si
nos fijamos en nuestra semi reacción de
reducción podemos observar que tenemos
un átomo de oxígeno del lado izquierdo y
ningún átomo de oxígeno del lado derecho
por lo que tenemos que agregar una
molécula de agua del lado de los
productos y ahora si ya tenemos un átomo
de oxígeno del lado de los reactivos y
un átomo de oxígeno del lado de los
productos y entonces la semi reacción de
reducción ya está balanceada con
respecto a los oxígenos también bueno
ahora vamos con la semi reacción de
oxidación por aquí tenemos un oxígeno
pero recuerda que este paréntesis con
este 4 de aquí
aplica a todo lo que está dentro del
paréntesis entonces en realidad tenemos
4 oxígenos del lado izquierdo y del lado
derecho tenemos 4 oxígenos entonces aquí
ya está balanceado el oxígeno así es que
ya terminamos con el paso 3 y vamos con
el paso 4 balancea el hidrógeno
agregando protones por aquí en la semi
reacción de reducción recuerda que en el
paso anterior agregamos una molécula de
agua
así es que agregamos dos átomos de
hidrógeno pero no hay ni un solo átomo
de hidrógeno del lado de los reactivos
así es que vamos a balancear esta
situación agregando hidrógeno pero en
forma de protones y queremos agregar dos
y entonces si tengo dos átomos de
hidrógeno en la izquierda y dos átomos
de hidrógeno en la derecha para la semi
reacción de oxidación recuerda que este
4 aplica también a este hidrógeno
entonces del lado de los rectos
tengo 4 átomos de hidrógeno pero no
tengo ningún átomo de hidrógeno del lado
de los productos entonces pues voy a
agregar 4 átomos de hidrógeno 4 pero los
voy a agregar en forma de protones y
ahora vamos a agregar electrones para
balancear las cargas y para hacer eso
necesitamos analizar las cargas totales
de cada uno de los lados de nuestras
semi reacciones y bueno pues vamos a
empezar con nuestra semi reacción de
reducción por aquí tengo dos protones o
sea que tengo dos cargas positivas y
luego también tengo una carga negativa
en el hipoclorito entonces tengo por
aquí una carga negativa y dos cargas
positivas más una carga negativa nos da
en total una carga positiva porque ahora
yo tengo la mala costumbre de escribir
mis cargas de la misma forma en la que
escribo mis estados de oxidación y eso
puede llegar a ser
confuso pero recuerda que aquí estoy
hablando de las cargas en este momento
pero bueno eso fue del lado de los
reactivos de la semi reacción de
reducción del lado de los productos por
aquí el año en cloruro tiene una carga
negativa que hay tiene una carga
negativa y el agua no tiene ninguna
carga entonces en total del lado de los
productos tenemos una carga de menos 1
ahora yo necesito hacer que estas dos
cargas sean iguales y la única forma de
hacer eso es agregar electrones y bueno
recuerda que cada electrón tiene una
carga menos 1 que hay una carga negativa
así es que si quiero que estas dos
cargas sean iguales lo único que puedo
hacer es agregar dos electrones de este
lado entonces voy a agregar dos
electrones del lado de los reactivos
eso nos aporta una carga de -2 ok eso
nos da dos cargas negativas y más uno
menos dos nos da menos uno que esos dos
electrones nos hacen pasar de una carga
de más 1 a una carga de menos 1 y
entonces ahora si la carga del lado
izquierdo es igual a la carga del lado
derecho así es que ya balance las cargas
agregando 2 electrones del lado
izquierdo aunque y entonces vamos con la
semi reacción de oxidación por aquí
tenemos un solo ión así es que la carga
total es menos 1 mientras que del lado
de los productos tenemos aquí un millón
con una carga de menos 2
- 2 y tenemos cuatro de estos protones y
cada protón tiene una carga positiva así
es que tenemos cuatro cargas positivas y
menos dos más cuatro es más dos que
tenemos menos uno del lado izquierdo y
más dos del lado derecho y tenemos que
hacer que estas dos cargas totales sean
iguales y la única forma de hacer eso es
agregar electrones si yo llego y agregó
tres electrones de este lado eso nos da
tres cargas negativas y dos menos tres
es menos uno aunque agregando estos tres
electrones pasamos de una carga de más
dos a una carga de menos uno y entonces
ahora si la carga del lado izquierdo si
es igual a la carga del lado derecho por
lo que ahora mis cargas si están
balanceadas otra forma menos directa de
averiguar en donde tengo que agregar los
electrones es recordar nuestra
mnemotecnia para oxidación y reducción
pérdida de electrones es oxidación y
ganancia de electrones es reducción
ahora si estamos perdiendo electrones
los electrones tienen que estar del lado
de los productos cierto mientras que si
estamos ganando electrones los
electrones tienen que estar del lado de
los reactivos y bueno de hecho esta es
una muy buena forma de verificar que lo
estamos haciendo bien
en fin ahora vamos con el paso 6 aunque
tenemos que hacer que el número de
electrones de ambas en mis reacciones
sean iguales y ahora la razón por la que
es muy importante este paso es porque
los electrones que se pierden en la semi
reacción de oxidación son justo esos
electrones que se están ganando en la
semi reacción de reducción y por lo
tanto necesitamos que haya exactamente
el mismo número de estos electrones ok
para que se puedan pasar de aquí para
acá ahora
justo como tenemos ahorita las de mis
reacciones estamos perdiendo 3
electrones en la semi reacción de
oxidación pero ganando únicamente 2
reducción eso no tiene sentido cierto
necesitamos tener exactamente el mismo
número de electrones en estas 12 mil
reacciones y la mejor forma de hacer que
las cantidades de estos electrones sean
iguales es pensar en el mínimo común
múltiplo de estos dos números y el
mínimo común múltiplo de 2 y 3 es 6 así
es que tenemos que hacer que en cada una
de estas dos semi reacciones haya
exactamente 6 electrones y para eso
tenemos que hacer esta semi reacción
tres veces
y esta otra semi reacción dos veces
aunque vamos a multiplicar toda esta
semi reacción por un 3 y entonces nos
van a quedar 6 electrones y vamos a
multiplicar toda esta semi reacción por
2 y entonces nos va a quedar 2 por 3 6
electrones así es que pues vamos a hacer
esto lo que estamos haciendo tres veces
esta semi reacción por lo que tenemos
tres por dos electrones o sea seis
electrones y luego tres por dos protones
o sea seis protones y luego tenemos tres
por uno que es el coeficiente que no
estamos escribiendo aquí enfrente de
lannion hipoclorito y tres por uno es 3
o sea que tenemos 3
aniones hipoclorito y luego el 3 por el
1 que es el coeficiente tácito de este
año en cloruro o sea que tenemos tres
uniones cloruro y finalmente tenemos
tres moléculas de agua
moléculas de agua ahora vamos a obtener
un poquito más de espacio y vamos a
hacer esta semi reacción de oxidación
dos veces que tenemos un compuesto de
cromo pero estamos multiplicando toda la
semi reacción por dos por lo que tenemos
ahora dos compuestos de cromo
y luego aquí tenemos un cromato pero
estamos multiplicando todo por 2
entonces tenemos 2 cromatos
y tenemos cuatro protones multiplicamos
todo por dos así es que tenemos dos por
cuatro ocho protones y finalmente
tenemos tres electrones pero lo
multiplicamos por dos y nos queda dos
por tres seis electrones y ahora si en
nuestra semi reacción de reducción
tenemos seis electrones y en nuestra
semi reacción de oxidación también
tenemos seis electrones así es que ya
logramos que nuestras 12 mis reacciones
haya exactamente la misma cantidad de
electrones y ahora lo que vamos a hacer
es juntar las 12 mil reacciones
nucleares seguimos actuando como si
estuviéramos en una solución a cívica
pero pronto vamos a tener que hacer un
paso más porque en realidad estamos en
una solución básica pero por el momento
vamos a juntar estas dos en mis
reacciones primero vamos a tomar todos
nuestros reactivos y vamos a ponerlos
aquí así es que por aquí tenemos 6
electrones
6 protones
6 protones más
cl o menos
r o h 4 - y del lado derecho tenemos
todos estos productos gay
los vamos a poner por aquí en total
tenemos 3 cl - +
es moléculas de agua más
cr 42 - + 8 protones
y electrones y listo bueno como podemos
observar tenemos 6 electrones del lado
izquierdo y 6 electrones del lado
derecho así es que pues podemos
simplemente cancelar los por otro lado
también tenemos 6 protones del lado
izquierdo y 8 protones del lado derecho
así es que pues podemos cancelar 6
protones y aquí quitamos 6 protones y
nos quedan dos protones y ahora ya que
lo simplificamos un poco más tenemos que
volver a escribirlo tenemos 3 cl o menos
más 2 cr o h 4 - y luego tenemos
cl - más
h2o más 20 ó 42 menos más no se nos
pueden olvidar estos dos protones de
aquí 2 h más
ahora sí tenemos que recordar que en
realidad está reacción está sucediendo
en una solución básica por lo que
tenemos que agregar unos aniones
hidróxidos para que neutralicen a estos
protones entonces lo que tenemos que
hacer es fijarnos cuántos protones
tenemos tenemos dos protones por lo que
tenemos que agregar dos uniones
hidróxidos y agregamos dos uniones ibrox
y dos para neutralizar a estos protones
ahora como estamos en una ecuación
balanceada todo lo que le hagamos al
lado derecho también se lo tenemos que
hacer al lado izquierdo
ok así es que por aquí también tenemos
que agregar dos uniones hidróxido si
agregó dos aviones hidróxido a la
derecha tengo que agregarle dos años es
hidróxido a la izquierda ahora tenemos
que ponernos a pensar en qué es lo que
pasa si agregamos dos años es hidróxidos
aunque resulta que estos aviones
hidróxidos con estos protones se van a
neutralizar se van a transformar en dos
moléculas de agua entonces del lado de
los productos vamos a tener dos
moléculas de agua más pero bueno ahora
con esta nueva información tenemos que
volver a escribir toda la ecuación
balanceada pero ahora sí vamos a obtener
la respuesta final del lado izquierdo
tenemos 3 cl - + 2
cr o h 4 - más no se nos puede olvidar
estos dos aviones hidróxido + 2
h y luego del lado derecho tenemos 3 cl
- max y aquí antes teníamos tres
moléculas de agua pero acabamos de
formar otras dos moléculas de agua
entonces en total tenemos 5 moléculas de
agua aquí también tenemos 2
cr 4 2 - y aquí estos ya se
transformaron en una molécula de agua y
listo ya terminamos ya tenemos aquí
nuestra ecuación balanceada que nos tomó
un montón de tiempo pero finalmente
tenemos aquí la respuesta ahora siempre
que tienes una ecuación balanceada es
una buena idea checar que realmente esté
balanceada ok eso se hace como te enseñé
en el vídeo pasado checando que haya la
misma cantidad de cada tipo de átomo del
lado izquierdo que del lado derecho y
que el total de las cargas del lado
izquierdo también sea igual alto
tal de las cargas del lado derecho pero
bueno en esta ocasión eso se queda de
tarea